convertir las cenizas en llama antes es
lo que proponen life game y eterna va
las dos empresas líderes del mercado en
eeuu
life quien fabrica diamantes a partir de
carbono extraído de restos incinerados y
mechones de pelo como recuerdo personal
el proceso reproduce las altas
temperaturas que existen naturalmente en
las profundidades de la superficie
terrestre hasta extraer carbono puro que
permite la producción de diamantes una
práctica que puede ayudar a los cercanos
del fallecido en su proceso de luto
starling a inglés wayne mail disfrute de
este viaje de conseguir este anillo
hecho significa mucho el nivel de
atención que tuvo eterna va conmigo es
inigualable me alegra haber elegido
hacer esto me alegra tenerlo para
siempre no importa donde me lleve la
vida a vanguardia de
white ex min en los últimos años la
gente dejó de lado los funerales
tradicionales y se popularizó la
cremación como proceso del final de la
vida durante la pandemia alrededor del
55% de los restos les fueron cremados ya
que el entero a veces ya no era una
opción en eeuu presenta chances y creo
que el reto para las familias
especialmente para las familias en duelo
es que la sepultura era el único ritual
que culturalmente teníamos y sin eso
creo que realmente hay una necesidad de
cosas y una experiencia como la nuestra
permite la creación de significados
haciendo rituales que te ayuden a través
de un proceso de duelo en cosas los
llamantes se pueden conseguir por un
precio de mínimo 3 mil dólares que puede
subir hasta 20 mil dólares o más